why do you love being in front of the
camera
i think really i became an actress and
a vlogger because
i'm getting the attention i didn't get
when i was a kid
and i knew i deserved it i knew i had a
lot to say
and i could say it in a really cute way
and
i knew right away that i was um uh
different first of all because that's
what they told me my mother
said you know in in yiddish it was
uh which translates
to you're gonna die alone um
no one will ever think you're normal
like she'd say you're not normal and i
i'm not oh
not normal people don't have friends
they have cats i mean lots of them
not that i'm against cats i love cats
dogs everything but
i want to be friends with humans i also
i want to be able to to work and have a
job
so i have to prove that i'm i'm not
crazy i'm normal
well i saw what my mother and father
paid attention to
the television so as a kid i knew
just be on tv people will watch you
plus people on television especially if
they were pretty
had great credibility and you know after
being told you're crazy you're crazy
you're crazy and in yiddish which makes
it a lot worse
your whole life you want to prove your
your normal
and being on tv makes people even crazy
people look
less crazy and i knew i could express my
opinions
and there i had the audience so it's
just a matter of like
how was i going to be on tv to express
who i was especially since i was a
terrible auditioner i really
sucked i would have been a huge star
if i were able to not lose my mind in
every single audition that i had a line
in it was funny i could always get the
parts when i didn't have lines that was
easy
but there was something uh that just
said do it right baby just
you gotta do it right and i think i was
trying to audition
the way i thought that the person who
would actually get the part would do it
which takes every all the creativity all
the put yourself into it
out of it and i was just trying to kind
and and i was
so insecure i i was almost like
every i start every audition with i'm
sorry can i start over
and um let me just let you go back to
your work casting the real people and
i'll go back to
driving back home out of the valley
and when i came to l.a i was 21
uh from montreal my car did not have air
conditioning
and so what most of the auditions were
in the valley and i would schmitz
and i i kept failing at auditions and
and i i was working at um the ihop
because you know working on my acting
skills like acting like i didn't want to
kill myself
at the cashier cash register i couldn't
even make change
someone give me a 20 i'd stand there and
cry you know it's like horrible
but i went through all that because i i
knew
one day i would succeed if i just didn't
give up
i was reading like napoleon hill and all
these like self-help books
because as an actress you get rejected
for a living and
and then um unfortunately
i was me tood into a state of
depression that i'm still
recovering from because every once in a
while some uh
horrible thing will happen uh show biz
related
man related and the trauma just comes
back
you know and uh so i have to deal with
that
daily too so i had a lot of um
very uh negative experiences when i i
came here
not just losing my self-respect i mean
uh i i came here to be on a tv show
um i i my parents bought me a car
where we were living in montreal and i
said thanks
and i drove south made it right at ohio
and then just
came right out here because i was going
to be on this show
and it turned out the show happened but
without me
and so i i was i saw it all happening
the producer apologized and
um i got drunk and so instead of getting
into show business i got into
hard drugs and i got sober
december 28 1982 but who's counting
and so i've been alcohol free and it was
a
a a journey back to
be the reason you drove here hanala
if you were to write a letter to
yourself
on that drive from montreal to ohio
then to california what would the first
paragraph of that letter be
i would say
turn around because montreal is about to
become
hollywood
you don't have to go anywhere and
then i would say but knowing you
you really want to tan and you want your
hair to look better because montreal is
very humid a lot of people don't realize
it's
a island in the river a volcano really
very very humid we didn't have air
conditioning i learned to suffer
i learned to have a lot of heartbreaks
in montreal so i would
say i know you want to get out of
montreal i know you really really really
really want to go but i
don't think you're ready you're too
sensitive
and the show's not going to happen
of course she drive here anyway
even if you had read that letter if
someone had read if
someone had written that you would still
have driven
well i i think that i had a real passion
to do this
and and i would uh i don't think that i
could have understood possibly
how i wasn't uh capable
of handling what was going to happen i
guess i would have had to
tell her you know you're you're gonna be
fed some drugs and then you're going to
wake up with a naked
man on top of you and you're going to
make it a joke like what is this naked
man i'm
doing on top of me you know i can't
figure this out
but um it's not a joke it will affect
you
forever and it will affect your
self-esteem
so much that you blame yourself and you
invite
more of the metoo experiences into your
life
and that it's going to be
a life of a lot of rejection so
maybe you want to like stay home a
little bit longer and
trust me about this montreal turning to
hollywood thing
but staying at home being told you're
crazy from from the people that i've
know that
that's like their go-to line usually
they've come from a lot of trauma
themselves
and that's how they kind of keep people
in their place
from the people that i've met that
that's like their running dialogue that
so would that really be an option
wouldn't it be better to come somewhere
new
get away from that
there was i there was a safety to be in
school
i could drink more responsibly
i did a lot of well i was in theaters so
we did a lot of drinking
i remember descending this staircase i
had the lead in the play
and uh they built a very high staircase
and even when i wasn't drunk it was high
and so i was waiting backstage for my
first entrance and the whole cast
backstage they were holding their breath
wondering if i was going to fall and i'm
like oh isn't being on stage
scary and they're like shh and i'm like
oh yeah they're going to hit my mark
okay i gotta
so i get to the top of the landing and
i'm looking back and
the rest of the cast is up there going
and i'm like i'm so relaxed right
because i'm so drunk
and i i hear my queue i open the door
and i'm absolutely perfect you see i
live with my mother and i was a drunk
and a drug addict so i knew how to like
act
i was an actress i could act straight
so i you know i was already pretty much
of an alcoholic
in montreal when i was doing all the the
plays
well no beef i started uh on the theater
on the stage when i was a yiddish
theater when i was
very little like four years old so i i
wasn't drunk then and i do remember the
experiences
and being terrified so i think that
whether i lived in montreal or whether i
lived in los angeles
i would still become a raging alcoholic
and drug addict
which came first your sobriety or
starting the cable access show
ah i started my cable access show
because i got sober on december 28 1982
4 pm if you're counting and i counted
every minute at that time
because i wanted people to understand
what it's like to live without killing
yourself
i didn't think i could get sober i only
got sober because my husband said he was
going to leave me
if i didn't get sober and i was an
agoraphobic and i lived through him
so if he left my life was over what was
i going to do well for a fedex guy to
come by
you know depends on what he looked like
i guess yeah but you can't count on that
no one was sending me packages no i
lost everybody but certainly the trust
of everybody
including my mother unfortunately the
holocaust survivor i felt so bad
both my parents being holocaust
survivors and here
i am throwing my life away but i i did
the best i could
um what was the initial question the
initial question was which came first
getting sober or the cable access
oh right right right so so when i was
uh well nothing could get me sober you
know i
on my own so when i uh
he threatened to leave me as i said i
couldn't have that
so i said well you know what i said this
to myself not to him
i'll go to one a.a meeting and i'll talk
about it for like a month
because my mother stretched a five-year
war into a 50-year story
i knew how to do this okay so i i
thought okay so i'll get my stuff
together i almost drank on my first
uh on the way to my first meeting
because i well i
i felt i merged better on vodka wrong
that's
delusional i no so
i thought it was inappropriate so i
didn't have the drink
and i was shaking like i said
agoraphobic so just leaving the house to
get the mail used to make me shake
and now i'm driving from the beach to
west hollywood
and so i'm like this but i got there
and that was my first meeting and i sat
down
i've been sober ever since that was my
last drink of alcohol
and i thought when i got sober that who
people need to know about this
so um it just so happens i was in a
building
with a public access studio so i
actually saw one but didn't think
anything of it
but then i read in variety foreign
actresses wanted
and i answered the ad and i said listen
i'm from canada
it's kind of like it's really foreign
enough
and she's oh come on down so i did a
show
and they all said in the studio
afterwards you should have your own
public access show
oh no now what am i going to talk about
working out because i've become an
aerobics instructor
and and sobriety and i created shape up
la and it was on for 15 years and then i
turned it into it
when i heard about this new thing called
youtube i'm like oh please
that's us on steroids right so i i said
i know how to do this
so i uploaded in 2006 and
almost 400 million views later
like so i like i said i knew
one um one pr company uh told me you
know you're
we can't we cannot call you a doctor or
therapist
because all you are is like a sober
person with a lot of great advice
and and uh you know what can we call you
and so we came up with life coach in the
80s
and then it caught on so in 1984 i think
it was i was on my first
tv show uh doing shape up la which then
they asked me to be on the other shows
because
i wasn't doing uh shape up uh
nebraska you know i knew where to do my
show
and uh so i i got on a lot of other
shows
and um i did movies
thank goodness one of the reasons i did
this show
is because seriously i suck at auditions
so
one time my agent called me and said in
the breakdowns
they want a they want okay my
at the time my name was susan stadner
but that's a whole other thing that's
before i took back my jewish name and
got married
but they said the agent called said
there's a breakdown in the breakdowns
they they're looking for a susan stapner
type
so he sent me and i didn't get the job
because they wanted the susan stadner
on shape up la not the one who sucks at
auditions
so that's why the show just had to be
the audition i did get a lot of work
like um they used my show starring me
finally in a movie called ruthless
people starring danny devito and bette
midler and
a lot of other really good stars and
i was the person they let me write all
my own lines
like i wrote us squeeze your thighs if
you don't no one else will
yeah or squeeze your butt anyway i wrote
all the lines
in there it was about like four more i
wrote that
but uh it was it was a lot of fun to see
my show
with a much better set and better
lighting
and as a matter of fact i thanked um
david zucker
the one of the producers director's
writers
brilliant wonderful love you david um
i asked him i i told him that i i wish i
had this gorgeous set
from my public access show to shape up
ballet it was all sparkles and colors
and he said well if you can haul it away
you can have it
but like i didn't have a backpack big
enough
or a crew because it's public access so
but
it was it was an experience to watch
that and then i did a zombie movie i
played an aerobics
star 2 on a tv show the zombie
is so mesmerized he lets the lead get
away it was a pivotal role
more more of the four more kind of
things but so i
i became known as like the actress you
hire
who plays in aerobics instructors you
can see i just let myself go
not right because you never know when
the next job will come up
you changed your name from susan to
hanala
how did changing your name change what
you do creatively
is susan still there is susan a memory
changing my name was um something that
happened
one thing at a time people don't
like why'd you go from susan stabner to
honolulu segal
well it's a little bit of a story when i
wrote my memoir
it was called my parents went through
the holocaust and all i got was this
lousy t-shirt
it took 10 years to write
it was 800 pages and then i took out the
blame
and then the commas and then what was it
what was the page
400. but i added pictures i'm an
illustrator
an artist so i was able to always ever
since i was a kid i have
all these cartoons that express how i
feel
and i'm actually quite good i i have
this ability
to draw someone just like they look
without having them there
i use a picture anyway but i know i i do
uh i i can do portraits but i um
um
i went through such a process over the
10 years of writing that book
that i think i became a different person
at the end and when my mom came to visit
um toward the end uh i didn't finish it
until after she died unfortunately
well what happened was we were at the
airport and
she looked at me with tears in her eyes
and i was already crying and she was say
it's not like i'm dead i'm like no
you're going to canada
but she said she teared up finally and
she said
oh you look just like hanola and that
was her sister she said
oh the people that come from the other
village just to talk to hanola
just to talk to hanala
damn i can't tear up yet okay so um i
went home
got on the treadmill still crying and
when my husband at the time that was two
husbands ago
if you're counting um and i said
pete i want you to call me hanala
you know like
why would you watch now and i explained
it to him
and he said okay he finally about three
years ago started calling me hannah it
took him a while he's a stubborn guy
so honolulu was a name that like my
therapist got right away
and she was all behind it yay but
then i became um
seagal when i married a seagull and
became an american
citizen while legally married as a
seagull
so to unseagall myself would have been
very difficult and expensive
so um you might say well why not just
get rid of the name
well i don't believe in throwing out the
baby with the bathwater
and i love the straight a's hana la
sagal
and it is pretty because otherwise it
would have been hanullah stadner
which doesn't seem right to me anymore
so i've been a honolulu for years now
and it fits it's gentle and when i was a
little girl
my mother didn't call me susan
uh she well actually she that's how she
called me when she was angry susan
but i never heard hanala angry it was
always
but it was never like although my sister
um you know everyone has that sister
she she tried to ruin it for me once too
i told her that i hear susan the way she
used to say it which
tends to be like susan susan
susan susan
which i didn't need to hear in my head
anymore so
when i told her that she went along
oh that's so like her which is why we
don't really talk
what i loved about watching trailers and
reruns
of your cable access show that you have
on your youtube channel
was the comments that were also
how people really related to you and
they felt a
kinship and they wanted to call because
back in the day of course there were no
you know youtube and
what was something that someone said
that you it it changed you one of these
messages
oh something positive i had a father
uh call with a heavy middle eastern
accent
and he said oh well i have to back up i
did a show
where i wore a little girl dress with
crinolines and my hair was up in
pigtails and bows
and and i had a face that could pass you
know for a little girl
and it was so cute and oh
so i talked as if i were an adult
explaining what it's like
to be shamed by adults and
the trauma and how it's hard to really
believe in myself and i hear know so
much and
and it's always like when i'm at my most
excited
that i get yelled at oops i forgot to
watch and how it makes me like
shrink into myself and and and i don't
understand when i'm being hit like what
i could have done and how i could i'll
do it better i don't know what i've done
but i'll do it better i'll do
i won't stop whatever but i did it all
with comedy because my comedy wellness
brand
was started back then i just didn't know
it was called a brand
you know so um this this man
said when he watched my show and it was
like 22 minutes
it made him understand what his children
went through when he yelled at them
and when he hit them oh wow and he was
determined to change it wow and i knew
that it's hard to stop doing a show
even though it doesn't pay you nothing
when you get calls like that
and also oh um okay so i'm i don't know
what like 25 years sober at the time
and i'm at a meeting i'm speaking and a
woman follows me in and she said can i
talk to you
and at that point i'm like is this about
my ex-husband oh no this is happening a
few years ago
because that women have stopped me to
tell me i don't ask dash and dying don't
ask
anyway so um so she said no i just need
you to know
that my husband and i used to watch your
show while we were on crack
and um and then one day we said
we should try a meeting and
they've been sober ever since
so it's like i planted the season i did
it with comedy because that's how i like
to learn i like to laugh i don't want to
be
i don't want to be lectured if you can
make me laugh
you have me you know
and you wrote the book um that now will
be turned into it'll be adapted into a
movie called trauma land
when you wrote the book um was all
comedy based as well you were trying to
make light of a serious situation yeah
i was too angry and resentful to make it
really funny at first
i needed i needed to release a lot of
that like i said release the commas
um but then uh um the
shorter it got the funnier it got i was
trying to make a comedy wellness
reduction sauce
you know just just bring it in to just
the
the yeah yeah and the screenplay
that's where it's i call it a comedy
just a dark comedy because
um the whenever it gets like
heavy there's a big laugh right after
i don't want a stressful movie
and because i'm able to make it funny uh
it was just a matter of like you know
what actually moves the story along
what is the funniest that's what
remained and then then you get your
actual because yeah we do in the movie
we flash back to my parents in poland
and my
most disgusting and pathetic
alcohol ears and although
there's nothing funny about the nazis my
mother and father especially my mom
she had a way of
like i this is me i i did you just make
that up
and she said yeah and i go oh i have to
write that down
that's how she was and so we used those
little gems
and my sister who we talked about who
you know
we we are not close did say something
that almost made me like
belch she said
she thanked me for the writing the book
she said it brought
ma back
so she read it over and over again just
to make my mother come alive again
though i did my mother was so in my head
it's it was kind of hard
ma me there's a difference of a vowel
you know so it was kind of hard yeah
that she has a very distinct voice
which is why casting the movie is going
to be interesting i wonder who's going
to end up playing mania
because this darling holocaust survivor
who's so just
so bright and adorable and she was
really my inspiration
and that's why i wanted to change my
name back to her sister
who died in a gas chamber which is one
reason i changed my name from hanala
to susan i forgot to say i was born
hanalan not susan
my sister looked at me and went uh let's
name it susan hanal is way too jewish
and you didn't want to finish the book
while she was still living no i
very much wanted to finish it i so much
wanted to finish it
i i she gave me the finish
we were alone in the hospital um but i
won't go there
because i will definitely cry and give
away the uh an important
scene so i'm wondering if you can talk
about how many times you've pitched the
idea for trauma land
and and and what was the response and
then why now
uh um
i don't think i would have finished the
script for trauma land
had i not had this track record with
elvis and nixon
um starring michael shannon
and kevin spacey and people i used to
say kevin spacey michael shannon by the
way
um if they don't know it won the tribeca
2016 centerpiece that's like
the prize so based on that
i was inspired to do this uh to finally
finish it i've been working on the
screenplay since the book came out
trying to adapt 2006. oh oh that's so
many
700 000 drafts
so not really not really uh but it just
felt that way
yeah no there's a lot of drafts a lot uh
so
but just starting over too just and what
i would do
is i would take like master classes
screenwriting i'd watch
film courage i get tips oh thank you
absolutely
and uh especially um when it came to
writing a synopsis or summary
i actually i would watch your channel oh
thank you you're welcome thank you
and uh you it's part of that work we
integrated seven actually used
absolutely so um and here's what
happened um
other people seem to believe it too like
wow you wrote and
you co-wrote and co-produced elvis nixon
now the truth is that i had been
given this offer that if i could
complete
a really good script about the meeting
when nixon met elvis
i could actually perhaps get it produced
so i had a deadline so for 30 days
first of all back then this was about
five years ago six six years ago maybe
what i did was i had to order the dvds
from netflix
to research this meeting that elvis had
with nixon
i didn't know anything about it so i saw
all the uh the people who were there
talk about it
and one of the the guys that i i saw
was jerry shilling and he said he was
there for the whole meeting and i went
and the whole trip and everything it was
a really interesting story and i also
read priscilla presley's book
and that changed everything that gave me
motive
and so i i thought i got it i don't want
to write a screenplay about
dead elvis boohoo you know i liked elvis
i don't want to write
yeah it was that's a tragic end so what
i did was i had just written two
screenplays
that i never even bothered pitching
because i thought they were getting
produced and fell through
that were buddy flicks and went i'm
gonna do it about jerry
and that's how i came up with the idea
of how to format the screenplay and
everything
so i i wrote the screenplay and then
kerry always wanted
to direct it and then he
added a little bit and became one of the
co-writers but
i'm the one who who fleshed out that
story i'm very proud of it
so i'm glad that we're able to use that
to get us to the next level with trauma
land that's why i finished it
because i had a feeling that people
would pay attention to a produced
screenwriter elvis nixon took you one
month to write
it was a challenge for it's a one month
challenge
well i think i think that all in all
from when i started the first page
yeah it was a month and we had a
director at the time
so i would send him my pages every night
and i found that was helpful too
so he was almost like a sponsor like
accountable yeah okay every night
i couldn't take a day off because ryan
was expecting
a page or two and i was inspired plus
i found out i really love writing
putting
words in men's mouths
okay get in there stay in there use them
so i um i i enjoy writing from
men's roles and so that was
like more fun for me like i said i'd
already warmed up on two other
screenplays
and um i felt like i knew elvis i was
already doing
elvis songs like in my band i sing
suspicious minds
and i was born the day elvis got his
first
gold record and he recorded i want you i
love you i need you
is that the way it goes i'm dyslexic
it's one of those it's
all of them but not necessarily
necessarily in that order
so um i i think that as a fetus i
heard elvis and then my parents never
had air conditioning so the windows were
open in the summer because i was born in
april
and so i think i was born into elvis and
so i
when when it came to writing him and
also i had uh
the elvis impersonator behind me i
really
really want this badge and um
so i i enjoyed writing it it was
actually
so much more fun than writing about the
holocaust and
alcoholism i cannot tell you
did you watch a lot of of reruns or
tapes or whatever you know like um
i mean youtube was when were you writing
this youtube wasn't this was
2011. so youtube was around
yeah yeah but it didn't have any uh
youtube did not have anything on this uh
meeting between elvis and nixon
interesting maybe a couple of videos
maybe a couple but i had to uh
i had netflix at the time and they had
the
uh the the dvds from the national
archives
and also i heard that the
most requested photo of the national
archives was
of elvis and nixon shaking hands in the
oval office
so it's like okay so that became like a
big part of it
and with the dialogue when you
went back in for revisions were you
cutting a lot of it down did you know
how elvis had a very spec
very specific way he spoke and so did
richard nixon
oh we had a lot of different drafts i
kept writing it and writing it and then
what happened was
i never knew if it was going to get
produced even though i was being paid
option money you know you don't know it
could have gone away
and then one day i get a call you know
that it's getting made
so it was like years between
and i had no idea right but
about three three years maybe
after i wrote it and totally given up
except for the option money
i decided to submit it to a film
festival
the page screenwriting festival
and i got notified after submitting that
there were 5 000
entries so like i stopped checking the
emails and then one day i get a phone
call
and they say aren't you interested that
you've made it into the finals
and i'm like but i i'm blocking your
emails now because it was spam like
no we were trying to get a hold of you
to tell you you've been in the
quarter final not quite that i can't
even say if quarterfinals final
semifinals finalists
whatever however it works again dyslexia
but um
yeah we we made it into the top 100 and
it did we didn't win
but it was a finalist that script
and i've been working on it the whole
time so that's
you know like not with the other two
guys that was just mine
but i did put their names on it because
i had to you know they
at one point did put in a word or two
i guess so i um uh
i gave up on on all of that after the uh
the thing didn't win and didn't touch it
again and then i got the phone call
the kevin spacey's been cast and
uh the movies ago
why do you think most people fail in
hollywood
most people fail when they come to
yeah well i have to say uh
obviously there's um a delusional
factor where you really think
it's not going to be as hard as it
actually is
i don't know if it's because humans are
maybe
um we're inspired by uh attraction
and like we see what
being a celebrity attracts a very
attractive
they're bright and shiny and they play
roles they play instruments you know
like i want to play for a living
so they the people who strive for don't
have a real idea of the hard work and
tremendous luck involved to being one of
the few that actually make it
so they're setting themselves up for
failure
and that's why um i thought i was always
a very practical person
and i thought well if i'm going to work
regularly and i can't seem to audition
well
i better create a public access tv show
because
it was before the internet and then once
the internet my own youtube
tool to use that was one of my tools
another
one was to write a screenplay that i was
able to act in although on elvis and
nixon the role that i
wrote for myself was given to
another actress who had a big
social media following oh
and knowing that that stuff happens
unfortunately and it's
devastating why do you think some people
are
able to pick themselves back up and
continue on
some people get mad and say i'm done if
the system's rigged
i'm going i'm driving back i did have
when i was
working at the international house of
pancakes
acting like i was okay with it i did
have a recurring
nightmare that uh i was being shot every
night there was a regular customer who'd
come in
and um and i was wondering to myself
why am i showing up for
this and when i woke up i called my
agent and told him to throw away my
pictures and resume
was done i was done and now um
at this stage of my life i can tell you
i'm done with being done i've quit
quitting
i can't seem to quit i if if there were
a way
uh i when youtube came along and i
started getting millions of views a
month
and then millions of views a week it was
like yes
and so i went full-on you know i'm gonna
just do this and
of course the views have dropped down
but that was inspiring too
it gave me my own venue but if i were to
do it for the
money i quit too there's no money in it
although i do get residual checks but
why the government would take
6 cents out of my 12 i don't know
but i do get residuals as you can see
what's the best year you've had in
hollywood
i thought the best year i actually did a
youtube video saying
30-year overnight success
[Laughter]
thinking that elvis and nixon was going
to be the best year here i'd
written this amazing screenplay it was
nominated and won
awards and starred big stars and all
that i
thought that was good and it was
actually one of the worst
because i didn't understand
although i've made it a joke in the past
how writers can be treated
and uh it was just not a happy
experience
at all however uh
one day i'll be able to watch the movie
and truly enjoy it but not yet
so was that your worst year because i
was going to ask you what was your worst
year
you thought it was going to be your best
that's why i guess it was the best of
years it was the suckiest of years
yeah um so both are true and
that seems to be the yin yang the real
thing you're
everybody's got something i don't know
anyone who's not dealing with
something and that was my something and
i think that's what you know i tell i
i would have told my myself in a letter
to my young self
it's always going to be something and
don't take it personally you're going to
get calls
from the big producers shaming you and
telling you who do you think you are
you're gonna get those phone calls don't
get it
don't take it personally it's men doing
their thing
to stop you from doing yours it's always
men did you get any i'm i've had a call
from a few agents that
said oh well you think you are yeah but
now you're not
talking man or woman now you're talking
career okay
occupation oh wow that's gender neutral
yeah
it would be yes yes and
i think that uh there's also other
things i would tell her
uh very important see people for who
they really are not who
you wish they were because this is a
town of people who will tell you
what they think you need to hear in
order to get
what they need from you so i would tell
her to
uh uh before google because this was
before
hell it was before laptops um i would
tell her
you're you're this it's a a town
full of people who will misrepresent
themselves
and check people out and don't trust
anyone be eighty percent less canadian
and twenty percent more fbi
and canadian is oh way you wouldn't hurt
me
because i wouldn't hurt you eh we're all
in this together
i hurt you that's like hurting myself
well that was a little
i'm from southern montreal south slips
and i can't believe i forgot how to do
i spent 21 years in in montreal
and now suddenly i can't do the accent
anymore
a and fbi is
guilty until proven innocent or
well in this town just know that
people do take advantage
i was told by my first photographer
let's just call it a headshot
session where he told me after he took
the pictures
that all the girls do this after and i'm
like
not ain't b you know all the girls all
of them
but um at that point you know he had
already given me something
and a glass of wine and i was happy to
do it because i was already freaked out
that i wasn't on that tv show i drove
here to beyond
so yeah do you think me too
will still exist in this current age now
with
this generation going forward because
now we're bombarded with it
every day on twitter somebody news being
called out
male or female well i i know someone who
absolutely hates the metoo
movement because it changed the way they
do business
and i'm like okay anytime anything is
new
there's going to be growing pains and
and
right now it's all like getting adjusted
as to what's proper
however now that women and girls
and boys are given the words
to use like that is not appropriate put
that back in your pants
you know it's like before we didn't even
have that's like oh it must be me was i
wearing
a like a short skirt i mean even though
we know it's not
the typical thing is uh i was raped
oh what were you wearing i mean that's
where we're coming from
so uh do i think it's gonna change
overnight no but
these people who are being uh
and and and as someone who's been
assaulted
if you're being sexually assaulted
you're being assaulted by
someone who is able to
objectify you and not think of you as a
person
and so if you are quiet you are
complicit
so not that you brought it on or not
that you let it go on
just know that you have to be a champion
you have to be the
hero right then and there and say
if i don't speak up now no one will and
i have a right to
no matter if they bought dinner rape is
definitely not okay
not not at all but then there's this
other element which feels like
sort of the elephant in the room in
hollywood and that is what if there
is you do this for me and i do this for
you
well the casting couch has always been
there favors you do
favors for people there has to be
that line of not
sex it just can't be you know it's uh
it's so hard to change the paradigm
what if somebody thinks they're
different i've got to do this
i've got to get this part the one thing
i see about this town and having been
young growing up not in in the industry
but then coming here at a very young age
with not a lot of guidance as i saw a
lot of people like myself that were very
hungry they would have done anything and
i see sometimes they're still
hungry and they're in their 30s 40s
that's why it's so to the industry they
can't it can't be offered you know it's
like
dude you know don't be one of them yeah
um get your sex elsewhere get your
thrills elsewhere
but i mean for for for women or men
because it's happening to men as well
what would you tell them that they think
that they'll be offered something
if they just do this and they're willing
to live with that
there oh yeah you know if you're willing
to live with that you know if you're
willing to
i mean there are people who have sex for
a donut you know
yeah i would never i never say one one
case
fits all however there has to be
you know something that we expect and
something that we don't expect and when
the don't expect comes in we're like
i know where to take that i know how to
report sure sure if it's
you're waking up and yeah but otherwise
i mean it's like
case by case right but do you think
we're still in that in that arena now
that there's been so much
so many people have i would imagine
people are more afraid to
whip it out these days if you laugh
life is what oh well
here's i live by laughs love acceptance
understanding gratitude and honesty and
that's basically i believe that
uh laughing is what will
save your mind and it's also
great ab work like singing
and acceptance is
where you basically pick what's
important to you
and you accept what you
can't change and then of course you go
and change what you
can that you can't accept and uh
understanding
i find would take a lot of the hatred
out of
what's going on today with society if
people understand
um the concept of like cognitive
dissonance which makes a lot of people
they're not open to discussion
and to changing their paradigm and
what they do is they defend and push
away but if you
understand what's happening i know
insecure angry people
are easy to brainwash and it's a lot
harder
to convince someone that they've been
fooled than to fool them
so if you understand that you're less
likely to be as angry when you're
dealing with what's happening today
and gratitude is remembering that we
could be dead i always think of
carrie fisher went through my drug rehab
um decades ago like 20
years ago or something and she was
exactly my age
and i know that she didn't stay sober
she just couldn't
and i always think about that could have
been me
if i'd still still be doing the coke and
and then i also think about how uh
i never killed anyone i drove drunk a
lot
because like i said it you know helped
me merge
and uh i didn't want to i thought only
bad people
drove under the influence but then i
became one
and again that was you know a war inside
me so i drank more but then i
you know i was able to actually get home
i'd always be shocked how my car was
parked and i
so i on days so they're really hard for
me now
i think about that that i never killed
anyone because i have been the
codependent canadian i'd never get over
that i mean
and neither would they or their families
so
um uh so just being grateful that i'm
not
uh an alcoholic and an addict
and destroying my life and others and
um honesty i have to be honest
with myself or or else i am i'll really
blow it
i'll get nervous and anxious if
i try to bury red flags
they will be buried up my butt and that
hurts
and so i've got i've got to look at them
before they go up there
okay so let's laugh right
the most painful thing you went through
as an addict
the most painful thing i went through is
an addict
wow which one i have to go back into the
rolodex
does anybody remember rolodex i do thank
goodness
um i would the first thing that popped
to mind as soon as we're in therapy
um and that's how this goes uh i
i have to say the having to drink
before a phone call and feeling so alone
and feeling like i was going to blow
every opportunity
and i was never going to reach my
potential and that was something that i
would feel
daily because i couldn't go out i
remember one time
taking a big hit off my bong
and then running down the stairs to get
the mail
because that's the only way i could get
the mail and i bumped into the mailman
and exhaled and i'm like oh my god i
could never get the mail now
like i blew my one thing i could do and
then i'd go back
up and and drink and also my husband was
going to leave me
so i remember like one time i was a bad
drunk and i was waiting for him to come
home
and i thought i wonder if i have time to
to
to pour myself a drink and i thought no
i'll have to drink it from the bottle
and i'm drinking it the bottle smashes
there's red wine everywhere
and it turns out i had enough time
because the guy never
came home that night he said yeah if you
were
such a drunk i'd come home and i said
sorry
so i think that was pretty painful
and then i also felt i was um with a guy
once accidentally
um oh accidentally well i couldn't be
alone
so just the one time i would go and go
out i'd usually come home with someone
like take
out you know only i bring home a guy and
he'd stay
you know um so uh one time
was it the mailman wasn't the mailman
was it no okay
no no um he was a guy at a bar
he said he was british but then i found
he was really from san diego when his
mother called
[Laughter]
i was gullible so wait where was i going
to get a guy
uh so you were saying something about
the agoraphobia agoraphobia but you said
ah i would see i got sidetracked because
i was going to ask you what happened
this makes me a good writer but not such
a great interview well no no i love the
stories
the the mailman when you exhaled on him
what happened what did you ever have to
say oh i don't know i just died a little
oh he never
never came out again okay yeah no no i
never saw him again or i don't think i
did
but i was already a little drunk at the
time or i wouldn't have mistimed it
right but you went to a bar you said you
always oh you would bring home take
out yes but what was the initial
question perhaps that'll get respect
the most difficult painful memories of
being an addict
oh yes i remember now thank you okay no
wonder i pushed it out
i turned to comedy comedy wellness okay
okay one time
i was with the guy who i'm the one who
pretended he was british
uh he hit me and i locked myself in the
bathroom
i was in the bathtub and i was shaking
and i said
ma i found my own nazis you know i made
how could i made my own holocaust i'm
like in the bathroom i was
you know and he tried to get me deported
oh my goodness
so um i think that that was probably a
low
i was kind of used to throwing up in
bathrooms all over town
um i because that's how i drank i drank
to the point of blacking out i
rarely remembered the end of the evening
or
look the same than i did at the
beginning of the evening yeah so um but
i never learned
i never stopped until i was able to
find some meetings where people were i
walked in
and they he were people sharing it you
threw up on
inspago's too oh my goodness what else
horrible embarrassing things have you
done the same things that i did
you know they found the men they found
the booze they found the drugs
and they weren't they were like sober
now and i'm like
okay i'm going to keep coming back you
know this is
yeah yeah this is this is something i
have to learn i have to read up on
but i didn't uh okay so the next day
they said
you see you can't share at a meeting
unless you have 24 hours of sobriety
and i was like a go i'm canadian a good
little alcoholic you know i wasn't going
to do that
so i thought how am i gonna get 24 hours
of sobriety
i thought okay because my plan was to go
to one meeting
go home and drink myself to death not
all at once eventually because i had
already had a bad liver report
at 26 at ucla they they told me my liver
was going i had a bad
liver panel and they told me to stop
doing everything i'm like i went home
and got so drunk because i thought oh my
god this is going to kill my mother the
holocaust survivor i'm going to die
before her
anyway so i got really really drunk you
know so um i
i thought okay how am i going to get
through this 24 hours so i can share
and um i was even offered cocaine
and it was incredible i just thought no
i must share
i must share once before i die i can
always die later
so i thought okay just get through the
night get through the night
and i did and i went to my next meeting
and i shared for the first time i put up
my hand
and i'm like you guys have taken cakes
and chips for like 10 years i can't get
10 minutes how do you do it
and this little old lady who's probably
about 10 years younger than me
turns around and goes oh honey we do it
one day at a time i'm like
like the sitcom heavy
okay i am gonna try this
and i just kept going a lot of meetings
and here we are
36 years later still sober because you
know i
learned first of all i didn't realize
the guy that i was living with
was bald and i didn't know he wore a
weave
oh how did you find out well it occurred
to me his hair was like unusually thick
you know that i'm sober i was like
getting a new pair of glasses there's
actually a book like that
so one night when he he's kept drinking
heavily
so i'm sober i'm like obsessed with his
hair
that was just so i'm gonna like i'm
gonna find out what's under there
so i i crawl over there very quietly and
i
lift the thing because he'd had a whole
bottle of wine
and i saw it was a weave it was like
stuck on
and then i realized his eyes were open
and he was looking at me
and i'm like i put it down i went back
to my side of the bed i
went back we never spoke of it but i
thought if i didn't know my own husband
was bald what else have i been missing
i better stay sober because
that would you would think that would be
obvious
what else what else did i get wrong
turns out a lot i got a lot wrong
do you think that's why storytelling is
important because you wanted to tell
your story which
was real and that is sharing in a
meeting and essentially you're telling a
story of
either your day or your life or what
you're struggling with
yeah and so then you get to do that with
writing or creating these
videos ever since i was a kid i created
the comic books
they had bubbles i wrote my words in
there words were always important i've
won
contests for writing even as a kid i was
published as a kid
always words were very important for me
to express what was going on and to put
them to
pictures you know my illustrations it
gave me
so much more expression that just
writing couldn't but yeah i had to be a
writer i had to
tell people uh one of the reasons i i
felt i survived in certain circumstances
was
i needed to tell someone what i went
through
which i i heard some holocaust survivors
say too
they survived because of luck
and the need to tell people what went on